make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so with Jonathan Hickman rebooting
the x-men and all that stuff what I want
to do here is I want to get into a
character explanation and talk about
Cyclops now of course like always when
we do character explanations we can't
really cover like every conceivable
thing but with Cyclops is doubly so
because he's been consistently part of
the x-men since their inception there's
never really been an instance where he
hasn't really been part of the team the
only exception to that is x-factor and
even then like they crossover all the
time so yeah I still kind of consider it
part of the protocol concept so in all
honesty there's gonna be sections where
we just cut out because we just don't
have time for it but wide in the clock
back to to really like Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby's run on the x1 when they first
debuted you know with issues 1 through
21 there wasn't a whole lot doing with
Cyclops and that's one of the things
that people tend to forget is they sort
of look at his character as he exists
now and assume he's always sort of been
that way the reality is the Cyclops
never really came into his own until
x-factor that was really kind of a big
thing that kind of big blowup moment
that set the stage for Cyclops becoming
that the character that we know today
but back in 1963 when the x-men first
launched it wasn't really popular and we
talked about that with the the team
right you were talking about that with
the x-men explained that it wasn't a
very popular concept that the teenage
element of you know young people with
powers was covered by spider-man and
what made him so popular was the fact
that it could be anybody under the mask
with the family dynamic and the
squabbles and the bickering and so on
and so forth the team element we got
that with Fantastic Four and so with
other characters who followed suit the
reality is that there really wasn't a
place for the x-men and in truth Stanley
created them because he was tired of
coming up with scientific explanations
for why people gain powers and so the
result was that by the time issue number
21 came around and Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby had essentially moved on other
things Stan Lee became editor-in-chief
Jack Kirby quit went to DC the result
was that Roy Thomas and then eventually
Arnold Drake came on as writers now
aside from like issue number 54 where
you basically get like the backstory of
Cyclops in the sense that he and is his
brother havoc who was introduced in the
same story they basically encounter each
other and you get this whole story were
essentially Cyclops and his brother were
thrown from a burning plane by their
parents and they believe their parents
have died in a plane crash
aside from that there weren't really
huge elements instead what a lot of
these stories did with Roy Tom is kind
of picking up the slack and trying to
salvage the title Arnold Drake
continuing that trend you basically got
more of like a character element of
Cyclops which is to say what he was
about and what he stood for when he
first appeared in x-men number one here
we got this kind of feeling that he was
like a big brother by the time we got to
Roy Thomas has run that I continued on
then Arnold Drake and then of course so
on and so forth but the reality is that
for the love to blossom between Cyclops
and Jean which was a huge part of their
characters it really came out of the
fact that Jean was a damsel in distress
right always needed help beyond being
saved and things along those lines
and so Cyclops always sort of being
there to rescue her ultimately led to
the two of them engaging in a romance
and so the result was that by nineteen
1975 when giant-size x-men came around
everything was essentially changing and
again we talked about this in the x-men
explained that when when it came to the
reader base of Marvel people didn't
really want to see that like the
traditional pretty white kids with
problems kind of story they wanted a
more dynamic and more diverse
representation in the comic book
landscape and so that's the reason why
you saw with giant-size x-men number one
from from Len Wein a multicultural
diverse set of x-men because at the end
of the day people wanted better
leadership we were coming out of the the
civil rights movement we were coming out
of the feminist movement and so there
was really more of a role of play for
characters that you wouldn't normally
see in stories now for it for his part
in this particular event because Cyclops
had kind of been the face of the x-men
up to that point the result was that
when the story picked up you ended up
having this scenario where Cyclops
arrived he basically told Charles Xavier
the mission took akoa was a failure you
ended up learning the krakoa was
basically this signal of sorts that
Xavier picked up on and said the
original x-men to go investigate all of
whom were captured and so of course
Professor X formed a new team with
Colossus and Nightcrawler and storm and
Wolverine and so on and that led to them
going to kokoa and then rescuing the
original x-men and so because of that
when this new team basically came
together that took place in uncanny
x-men issue number 94 and now to explain
that for a second why the time issue
number 63 came around from Marvel from
simply just x-men issue number 63 the
result was that that the tunnel was
essentially canceled and then it was
reprints for 30 issues and so by the
time he got to issue number 93 it was
just reprints of old stories and so
that's the reason why it continues on to
issue number 94 the difference is that
the title x-men was changed to uncanny
x-men and it kind of went forward with
Chris Claremont riding now the funny
thing about this and this is one of
things people sort of look at when they
think about Chris Claremont's x-men run
is they sort of can consider like
Cyclops to be one of the the focal
points of the of the stories at
Claremont told it's actually not true
when Claremont took over one of the
first things he did was basically kind
of reinvigorate and make Jean Grey
interesting because as the damsel in
distress
she was a care to know what he cared
about and so Claremont's argument was
one let's write the
x-men like a soap opera where there's
basically we're focusing more on the
characters and we are on the stories and
then too
let's elevate Jean Grey to a super high
level and then send her off on a high
note because the reality was at
Claremont was systematically riding out
all the old x-men and so with the
Phoenix saga going into the Dark Phoenix
saga of course as we covered in in that
particular story Jean Grey was elevated
she became incredibly powerful and then
she sacrificed her life and so what this
did is it allowed Claremont to remove
Cyclops he was really the last missing
piece the last part of this puzzle that
Claremont had to get rid of and so
following the events of the Phoenix in
the Dark Phoenix saga because of the
fact that Cyclops his parents had owned
a fishing company based out of Anchorage
Alaska that's where he went to and so
what you got
was it really back up features it was
more side stories in the uncanny x-men
where Cyclops was just kind of residing
in Anchorage Alaska minding his own
business doing his own thing and just
sort of enjoying this time of peace and
quiet now that's when Chris Claremont
began to began to sort of complicate
things and the reason why was because
what this did is it led him to the
introduction of Madeline Pryor now
Madeline Pryor at the time of her intro
we didn't really know anything about her
all we knew is that she was the spitting
image of Jean Grey that when Cyclops and
his family had a had a family reunion of
sorts that this led to the introduction
of Madeline and then of course the two
of them immediately hit it off now what
this does is this transitions forward
and then it jumps into the whole element
of x-factor but one thing that I do want
to cover before we get too far is the
love triangle between Cyclops Wolverine
and Jean because this was a huge part of
his character with Chris Claremont
focusing on the the character element as
opposed to the storytelling element
introducing Wolverine as kind of like
the bad boy the mysterious bad boy
nobody really knew anything about versus
Cyclops who was for the most part kind
of like the good soldier right I mean he
fought the good fight he was kind of
like the boy scout of the team the
leader he was a really a nice guy
insofar as he let people walk all over
him but the fact that there was kind of
a love triangle going on here introduced
the possibility that Jean Grey may leave
Cyclops and end up going with Wolverine
and at the time that was a huge deal
because of the fact that their love was
just such an intricate part of their
storytelling to have that sort of
abandon to have that walk away which is
entirely possible would have been
mind-blowing but of course as we know
that never really happened I mean Jean
Grey kind of toyed with the idea of
getting with Wolverine but ultimately
she never really did she ended up
staying with Cyclops and so going into
the launch of x-factor originally this
was done by Bob Layton and this is kind
of the funny thing about it is because
with uncanny x-men by Chris Claremont
being so exceedingly popular through a
combination of the readership Marvel
editorial and and really
like Bob Layton himself there was a
desire to kind of see a return of the
original x-men because the question that
was asked was if Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
launched the original team and it wasn't
that popular but we've now moved into a
new age of storytelling thus a lot
darker a lot grittier and so Bob Layton
wanted to basically bring the entire
team together now
for the characters of Iceman angel and
beast it was exceedingly easy just yank
him off the teams they're on throw him
into the x-factor team and you're done
with Cyclops and Jean Grey it was a lot
more complicated now of course gene
basically returned by way of the fact
that it turned out the Phoenix you know
was never actually Jean I said it was a
Phoenix force impersonating gene for
Cyclops is a little more nuanced because
he basically moved on and the Chris
Claremont x-men comics he'd walked away
like he was done being an x-man he was
finished with all that he had settled
down he was gonna have a child with
Madeline Pryor who was pregnant he was
ready to kind of go off and do his own
thing and so what ended up happening is
that within the first issue or two of
x-factor what you got was basically the
return of Jean Grey you know once Jean
Grey popped back up again Cyclops was
brought to New York by angel who
essentially said hey look I'm basically
financing the team I've got a buddy of
mine from college named Cameron Hodge
who turned out to be a bad guy who's
basically our public relations and
marketing guy this is Jean like she's
back again we want you to join an
x-factor and the way the Cyclops was
written because of the fact that he and
gene were previously married and because
of the fact that she was now back
without any real notice whatsoever
he abandoned Madeline prior in his
unborn son and this was very very big
when this happened is something that you
never really saw there's one of those
things where people sort of looked at it
as Marvel kind of sanctioning the idea
of a father abandoning his wife and
child but the result of this is that it
allowed Bob Layton to write the first
you know five issues or so after which
he left and then Lewis and Walter
Simonson to take over the title and for
Louise and Walter Simonson with Lewis
riding and Walter drawing the idea was
to look at this from the perspective not
necessarily of a reboot to ignore
everything that had happened before
largely due to the fact that because of
the way that Chris Claremont wrote the
x-men continuity was a very very big
thing they required them to kind of
continue on where things left off and so
the result was that the way Cyclops was
written under the x-factor Comics who
basically depicted him in such a way to
where the action of leaving his wife and
child really haunted him and so as a
result of that the relationship between
himself and gene was strained and
ultimately he never really found any
satisfaction outside of like leading
x-factor now for its part
x-factor functioned as a as a group that
would basically go around and find
mutants whose powers had manifests
and then train him in the x-factor
facility any reason for that was because
you know when the team was originally
launched Jean Grae had looked at the
x-men as they existed following her you
know time and stasis in a cocoon in
Jamaica Bay and believed that they had
basically straight away from their path
that they weren't really the team they
were supposed to be and that x-factor
was essentially going to be better and
so the result of this is that over the
course of the next few years
x-factor proves itself to be resounding
ly successful and in fact there were two
major stories that really came out of
x-factor itself as well as like
crossovers including like mutant
massacre things along those lines really
kind of getting into the two of these
things they went by the stories Inferno
and then x-factor endgame with inferno
this really kind of followed up and
really basically dealt with Madeline
Pryor right kind of way to just sort of
write her out and kind of have her done
with go on and do her own thing and then
Marvel could do whatever they wanted and
then with X I'm sorry with an x-factor
in game this is a way to deal with know
with Nathan summers the way to deal with
the character that would go on to become
cable and so what you had is following
cyclops leaving the X I'm sorry leaving
up Madeline Madeline eventually sawed
off the x-men she spent time with them
and then ultimately felt abandoned by
them just like she did with Cyclops and
so the result is that she made a deal
with a couple of demons and then
eventually just kind of gained all these
crazy powers and then led like this
massive demonic invasion of New York
City now of course ultimately she was
defeated but the big thing to come out
of that in relation to Cyclops was the
origin of Madeline that basically
somewhere along the line the villain mr.
sinister had come to the conclusion that
if Cyclops and Jean ever had a child
that child would be absurdly powerful
and so in order to to use that child as
a means to destroy his creator the
villain apocalypse Madeline Pryor was
cloned from the genes of Jean Grey and
then in turn sent to initiate a coupling
with Cyclops now when this happened we
didn't really get a whole lot of
explanation in terms of how sinister
knew that Cyclops and Jean were gonna
have a powerful have a powerful child
that didn't come until 91 with the
adventures of Cyclops and Phoenix right
so that really kind of explained that
whole backstory that basically Cyclops
and Jean Grey were time-displaced they
met mr. sinister a couple hundred years
before the modern day and that's when he
ended up realizing they would become
incredibly powerful or they would have
an incredibly powerful child now with
the villain apocalypse realizing what it
was that that mr. sinister wanted to do
this initiated the events of x-factor
endgame and this basically saw
apocalypse realizing that this child
would be incredibly powerful and would
make a perfect host for his body for his
essence and so what apocalypse did was
send his forces the Dark Riders out to
kid
Nathan summers and then he infected him
with a techno-organic virus basically
this virus that turns living a turns
living tissue into machinery now that
was done to test Nathan to see whether
he would be a viable host but the
actions of apocalypse also saw him
invading the inhuman city of Attilan and
so because of this the forces of
x-factor and the Inhumans band together
and then faced off against apocalypse
and then almost lose but ultimately
apocalypse is defeated he's forced to
retreat and this leads to a woman from
the future who turns out to be the time
displaced child of Jean Grey and Cyclops
basically whisking Nathan away into the
future where he goes on to become cable
but the reality is that at this point in
time Cyclops was really kind of
established to be a leader he was
established to be a curator that would
go on to elevate and and become the
version that we know today right like
x-factors set the seeds for all that it
set the stage for all that by the time
we got into 1991 uh you ended up having
Lois and Walter Simonson who basically
walked away or at least an 92-93 is when
they ended up leaving but around that
time between 1991 and 95 there was a
huge reshuffling of the x-men and the
reason why was because it had basically
hit a fever pitch right the x-men were
as popular as they had ever been an
x-factor was equally popular and so the
question for Marvel is why not roll X
Factor back into x-men keep the readers
from having to read about two separate
teams and then in turn have one team
that's split into two books and so you
got uncanny x-men which continued on and
then you've got basically the second
iteration of Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's
x-men that's why it's called x-men vol 2
and so this basically led into Cyclops
having his own his own kind of field his
own group that he would take care of
that he would send out on missions
various things like that storm would
lead the other of course you know that
really came on the tails of the events
when Cyclops faced off against storm to
determine the leadership of the x-men
once he left to kind of go out and do
his own thing storm of course ended up
winning and the result was that she was
capable of leading the x-men herself but
from that point really going into like
the the early to late 90s I'm sorry the
early to mid 90s and going into the late
1990s this is when things begin to
change
because for the most part by the time we
got to 1995 the big comic bust had
happened right the comic book fan base
and almost killed a comic book industry
by just kind of buying up a whole bunch
of different colleges or a whole bunch
of comments and then essentially
tricking publishers into believing that
there was a lot more popularity with
comic books than there actually was and
so the result of this is that from 95
running up until about 2003 2004 there
wasn't really any room to focus on
Cyclops outside of him just kind of
being there you did get stories like
like the 12 which basically
saw the villain apocalypse gathering 12
particular mutants that represented
different facets of power and then
trying to channel their power into him
ultimately it didn't work and instead
the essence of apocalypse went into
Cyclops and he just kind of walked
around for a little while um by the the
mid-1990s Emma Frost had basically
walked away from being a villain and
became a hero and in fact led her own
x-men team called Generation X there
were a lot of things that were going on
with regards to reshuffling the entire
landscape and so by the time you got
into the early 2000s you ended up having
Joe casada come on as editor-in-chief
and Joe Quezada began to shift up a
whole bunch of different things for
Cyclops in particular this was of
important note especially coming out of
the events of house of M and the reason
for this is that in in the late 1990s
with Marvel's struggling financially
their goal was to produce as many comics
as they could or produced the comics
they had in the cheapest way possible
and so paying writers in-house rates was
incredibly expensive paying artists
in-house rates was incredibly expensive
and so that's why you ended up having
Jimmy Paul Miyagi and Joe Quesada come
in as event publications and basically
say hey look we have our own writers we
have our own artists will produce these
comics for a fraction of a price you
know for the comics that aren't selling
particularly well you can keep those
going and we'll do it at a much cheaper
rate so that's why you ended up giving
getting a Marvel nights you got the
century you got Marvel nights
Luke Cage got Marvel Knights daredevil
in fact you actually got a Marvel
Knights team but the reason why this
matters is because following Marvel
basically being rescued financially by
Ike Perlmutter and and avi arad
and then Joe Quesada being moved over to
editor-in-chief it was kind of a chance
to do over write like a chance to sort
of financially be viable and then look
at the x-men as a whole and basically
say like how can we fix these things and
so casada lo did the entire landscape
and said okay basically everything we've
been doing for the last 10 years doesn't
work it almost bankrupted us we need to
basically go back to our base roots we
need to kind of get rid of all this
unnecessary nonsense and so the result
was that you ended up getting a series
of stories Avengers disassembled which
saw the disbanding of the traditional
Avengers team to be replaced by New
Avengers written by Brian Michael Bendis
um you saw really saw spider-man's
marriage to Mary Jane Watson being
removed and then one of the things you
saw with the x-men was a massive
reduction in power and this is where
Cyclops really began to shine this is
work a lot of the work that was done by
Walter and Louise Simonson on X Factor
really came to fruition for those who
guys should have a red house of am not
going to go super in-depth into it but a
seriously the big conclusion that came
out of it was that Scarlet Witch took
away 98% of the mutant populations
powers
the multiverse essentially there were
only 198 Newton's left but the other
half of this is that Charles Xavier was
missing and so again there were there
were huge moments that really took place
here and none of these were really as
significant as the moments that kind of
came out of Grant Morrison's new x-men
so kind of jumping back to 2001 for a
second with Grant Morrison writing the
the new x-men line of comics it was a
huge reinvigoration for the title
because Grant Morrison was part of the
the English and/or the British Invasion
in the 1980s right so writing like Doom
Patrol different things like that
in 1998 he wrote the the return of the
Justice League after the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths which was
hugely popular so it caught the
attention of Marvel it basically brought
a man and said reinvigorate the x-men
and so doing things like changing up
their costumes putting Emma Frost and
Cyclops into a relationship essentially
Jean Grey having already been back for
some time but basically writing things
in such a way to where Jean Grey and
Cyclops are moving further and further
apart or at least has seemed that it
seemed to be that way what this meant
was that by the time you got into the
House of M aftermath and the death of
Jean Grey during Grant Morrison and
Chuck Austin's run on the x-men this
basically meant that like this stage was
set for Cyclops and Emma Frost to be
together and that's why it is that if
you're reading x-men really like in the
last five years with Emma Frost and
Cyclops being over being in a
relationship being together that's where
all that came from it goes back almost
15 years a little more than 15 years
actually probably closer to 18 or 19
years and so because of that the
important thing that happened here was
that with Charles Xavier missing after
the events of house of M it now fell
upon Cyclops to gather together what was
left of the x-men and then basically
keep them safe and that's why things
really began to shift for his character
the reason why I say that is when you go
into the mid to late 2000s it was a very
very fast-paced time for the x-men
a lot was happening one of the big
things that really came out of the
aftermath of house of M and the fact
that only 198 mutants were left was the
question from the fanbase are we ever
going to see a proliferation of mutants
of you know were you ever gonna see a
scenario where meetings begin to like
rise in prominence yet again so
following this you had a whole bunch of
people who were writing all kinds of
different titles but one of the big
things that came out of this for Cyclops
was the was a story of x-men deadly
Genesis now of course x-men deadly
Genesis was released back in 2006 and
was written by Edie Brubaker
this essentially introduced the notion
that during the original giant-size
x-men number one there was actually
another x-men team that nobody knew
about when the original x-men were
cinder cacoa before Cyclops came back
ultimately he had this sort of
telepathic experience where all the
x-men seemed to have died
and so he formed a secret team which
consisted of like Darwin and Vulcan the
third summers brother of Cyclops that we
didn't know gabriel summers as well as a
handful of others all of whom appeared
to have died in the entire conflict now
of course we ended up learning that
because darwin can basically adapt that
what he did was kind of merge his life
essence with with gabriel summers and
then keep him alive but this was a huge
kind of reveal for Cyclops because what
it did is a cast Charles Xavier in a
whole new light where Charles Xavier
eventually returned after the events of
house of M the stance of Cyclops as he
was written between Edie Brubaker and
others was that he's been picking up the
slack all this time he's been the one
running the team basically Xavier can
shove off was really the overall tone
that that Cyclops had this combined with
the revelation that he had that there
was a second x-men team that nobody knew
about who were basically sent on a
suicide mission really cast Charles
Xavier as being somewhat of a villain in
the eyes of a lot of the x-men and that
became important because with that
happening that kind of resentment that
Cyclops felt as well as sort of going
through and you know becoming more and
more extreme becoming more in line with
Magneto's views in terms of how the
waters should be charted between humans
and mutants led eventually to Avengers
vs. x-men when Cyclops killed Xavier and
so it's kind of a huge ongoing series of
events that ultimately led to this but
with regards to that to the question
following house of M of whether or not
there would be of proliferation of
mutants Edie Brubaker wrote a story
called Messiah Complex and this dealt
with the the really like the return of
Hope Summers R I'm sorry the the arrival
of Hope Summers out the birth of her
character and the possibility from
cyclopses perspective that mutants could
begin achieving numbers that were
relative to where they were at least
comparable to where they were before he
is for extinction when sixteen million
of them were wiped out as well as the
House of M when the remaining 98% lost
their powers and so because of that it
really saw Cyclops functioning in a more
extreme way sort of moving and moving
him in the more extreme scenario in the
sense of we have to keep our own safe
anyone who could who does anything that
can endanger a mutant is now an enemy
over the course of the next few years
you know running up through the events
of of Messiah Complex utopia this began
to see slot cops becoming more in more
extreme now for utopia itself this came
out of the events of dark rain for the
x-men they actually ended up receiving a
kind of a hunk of land that they could
basically use off the coast of San
Francisco there was provided for them by
the mayor who is mutant friendly and
this basically began the process of the
x-men operating and really Cyclops
leading the team out on utopia outside
the United States jurisdiction instead
to sort of existing
out there but again he was becoming a
lot more extreme you know under the
riding that was being done by Ed
Brubaker by Rick Remender a lot of the a
lot of the actions of Cyclops are
following y'all falling more and more in
line with him becoming a magneto esque
kind of character you know in the sense
that he was becoming a bad guy and so
all this really began to come to a head
once we got to Avengers vs. x-men back
in any over and in 2012 now of course
this basically dealt with the character
of Hope Summers who had kind of just
been a sort of character who was there
you notice kind of the last vestiges of
what was essentially everything that
took place before the heroic age started
in 2010 and with with her character with
the Phoenix returning the question was
if it bonds itself to hope who really
seems to be the only real candidate for
the Phoenix force did what will that do
right because she comes from a future
where you basically had the six-second
war where Hope Summers attained all this
power and then wiped out a million
humans in six seconds and so fear came
from the Avengers that she would
basically become the new Dark Phoenix
whereas Eickhoff saw it as a way to
basically bring the x-men or bring the
mutant population back to fruition I
said what this did was it led to a
conflict between the two of them the
Avengers who wanted to take host summers
and bring her in and the x-men who
wanted to keep her safe and so of course
a massive conflict broke out between all
of them now this of course led to the
Phoenix eventually returning Aletta Tony
Stark trying to destroy it and then the
Phoenix splitting into five sections one
of which bonded to Cyclops himself and
so where the Phoenix 5 you know turned
earth very much into a utopian landscape
this also ended up deal it also ended up
having Cyclops coming face to face with
with Charles Xavier and with Cyclops
becoming more and more extreme with him
becoming more and more radicalized it
basically came to Xavier telling him
you're not the person that I raised
right you weren't like a son you're not
the the the x-man that I remember and
Cyclops was essentially like yes I'm so
much more and Cyclops killed Charles
Xavier he was a huge shift right it
really was like patricide it was really
like a child like a son killing the
father and so the result of this is that
Cyclops really crossed a line that he
couldn't come back from and so what it
meant was that going forward you ended
up having events like like quit enquirer
launching a revolution in the x-men
mansion you ended up having the events
of schism where you had a Cyclops and in
Wolverine who who just couldn't see eye
to eye a Cyclops ended up taking some of
the x-men and keeping them for himself
and then Wolverine took other x-men to
what was now called the Jean Grey
Institute of higher learning and then
basically you know had his own x-men
team the x-men lost her in a lot of ways
was basically split and a lot of it
really came down to the actions of
Cyclops he came down to the things that
he'd done that kind of
that he'd pulled and so as a result of
this by the time you got into the events
of secret Wars you ended up having of
course the collapse of the multiverse
after the accident for the most part
Cyclops was kind of like hey look we're
doing our own fee here you know we'll
step in if things need to happen but for
the most part we're doing our own x-men
thing this led to him revealing that he
had what was called a phoenix egg
basically a fraction of the Phoenix
force which he bonded to and then one
forward throughout the events of secret
wars now he was killed very early on he
was killed within the first three issues
of the story so there wasn't really a
whole lot doing for his character
instead once you came out of that and
and you went back into you went to
all-new all-different marvel things kind
of continued on with business as usual
well I wouldn't really say business as
usual as best as I understand it from
the interviews that I've seen what had
gone on at this time was that Marvel
kind of had this editorial mandate to
push the Inhumans as opposed to the
x-men largely due to the fact that Neil
Marvel was just kind of being pissy the
Fox wouldn't give the rights to the
x-men back in movie form and so what you
ended up getting was basically the death
of Cyclops and the fact that he was
essentially killed by the Terrigen mists
which really kind of begs the question
when Quicksilver was exposed to the
Terrigen mists why didn't it kill him
when his daughter was exposed to it who
was a mutant why didn't it kill her I
mean it's it's one of these things it's
kind of weird
in terms of why Marvel kind of pulled
the stuff that they did there was a lot
of continuity errors a lot of things
that didn't make sense it was one of
those stories it was just kind of pushed
out there and it was like don't ask
questions just read it and accept it
which fans didn't they they actually I
hated it everybody hated it but
following that Cyclops was dead and
Cyclops remained dead for quite some
time there was the whole Brian Michael
Bendis you know young x-men from the
past and Marvel kind of tried to push
them a little bit but fans weren't
really having it fans one of the
original Cyclops back and ultimately he
ended up making his return during the
events of the return of Jean Grey now of
course this was a short series but
essentially it was at Jean Grey had
already returned somewhere along the
line and that she was essentially using
the power of the Phoenix unwittingly to
create her own sort of pocket space by
this little section in the world
where everything was actually remembered
it and so far as her little life when
she was younger she had this sort of
peaceful scenario and Cyclops was still
very much alive not while this wasn't
really the tried and true side cup so we
had come to remember instead it was just
kind of a facsimile that the Phoenix had
created what it did is it set the stage
for the for the actual return of Cyclops
and uncanny x-men vol 5 annual number
one and the reason why was because fans
were ready to see him return and Marvel
was ready to bring him back largely
because the deal had already been worked
out between between
Marvel and Fox bought basically like the
x-men are returning to prominence once
again and so with it being written by ed
brisson what you ended up getting was
this sort of revelation that when
Cyclops is facsimile was created by the
Phoenix that when Jean Grey ultimately
chose to walk away from the Phoenix
force and let the Phoenix kind of go out
and do its own thing
the Phoenix would essentially place a
piece of itself inside of Cyclops to
resurrect him from the dead and so with
the help of cable who'd return from the
future albeit in a younger form Cyclops
ended up returning ended up manifesting
and he's basically been back ever since
there's a lot to cover when I when it
come you're talking about a guy who's
been around since 1963 right so you know
quite some time he's been around for a
long long time and of course he couldn't
really cover everything just because
there's so much stuff to throw in but I
do kind of miss doing these character
explanations I really do miss you know
running over all these things with
characters you don't have such a lengthy
history it would allow us to get a lot
more in-depth in terms of the meat and
potatoes and focusing on like why
writers did what they did and things
like that but what Cyclops is not really
a possibility because there's just so
much oh that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain it make sure
you guys with the sub button to become
part of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace